when I was young I found an orphaned  wolf cub in the forest 9r farm I felt if  I could instill rules the proper  boundaries I could harness the power of  that beast a few months later while  hunting adolescent turn  we're fixing the damage the Avengers did  all those years ago Inhumans are sick  unlimited power that's dangerous it's  lethal  lucky to be alive come on Kamala let em  help you I'll take my chances what if  the Avengers were set up I think you  should see for yourself  could mr. stark help us with this hi I'm  sorry who are you oh come on it's better  be good you tried to drive the Chimera  have you completely lost your senses  where were you while the world went to  hell this is our fault all of ours you  really think the world is better without  us yes it's always been improved running  from who you are what you are  [Music]  with many  [Music]  you  please